[Musique]
une convention a été signée au palais de
la source entre le département la région
et la sophie d'air pour la mise en place
d'un fonds de garantie d'un million
d'euros afin de permettre aux porteurs
de petits projets dans les hauts de
l'île de bénéficie d'une avance sur la
subvention feader
aujourd'hui il ya eu effectivement la
signature d'une convention entre la
région le département et la sophie d1
parce que nous sommes rendu compte que
les fonds leader qui sont dédiés aux
eaux dans le cadre du fonds feader les
fonds européens ne sont pas abouties et
ne sont pas utilisés par les acteurs
locaux du territoire les porteurs de
projets
faute de trésorerie il était important
pour nous d'apporter ce soutien
financier au travers du passé de ce
partenariat avec la sophie d'air donc
justement pour apporter cette ligne de
trésorerie aux porteurs de projets pour
qu'ils puissent réaliser et démarrer
leur projet au sein de leur territoire
j'étais important gage de cette
convention passée que les porteurs de
projets a trop souvent ont dû remiser
leurs projets dans les tiroirs faute
d'un début de financement à travers ce
qui leur propose aujourd'hui sa le
permet tout simplement de débloquer leur
projet puisque sur quelques 10000 euros
concernant un projet
la caisse la solitaire avec bien sûr la
caution du département aux deux tiers et
la région entière permet que ces projets
soient financées au moins en hauteur de
4500 euros ce qui n'est pas évidemment
négligent un dispositif qui aidera les
porteurs de projets à lancer les
premières démarches afin de permettre
une réelle dynamisation du développement
des os
[Musique]